[Music]
you may have just discovered Zach Haran
so there might be a few things you don't
know about him yet stay tuned to find
out what makes Zach's perfect dream girl
Zach and I'm from Dallas Texas are you
new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for a more great content
like this now on to 20 things you didn't
know about Zach Herron from why don't we
he grew up singing a lot of times when
singers burst onto the scene we all
wonder where they came from and even
more importantly how did they get such
amazing vocal talent
well Zach's talent didn't just pop up
out of nowhere he actually grew up
singing when he was younger he's sing in
a youth choir while in the choir he
always tried to get the solo parts
because he loved singing so much we
wonder if his choir instructor gave him
most of the solos if it were us we
definitely would have have you heard his
voice come on there's no way you
wouldn't want him singing as much in
your choir as possible
he's been touring you may think that
zach is new to this touring game but
that isn't the case come on he's a
natural there's no way this could be his
first time touring and singing and it
actually isn't that joined impact in
2016 impact was a meet and greet tour
that allowed up-and-coming stars to
travel around the u.s. and go to some
major cities while there they would meet
with their fans sing for them and sign
autographs it's a great way to solidify
your fan base and get to know them even
more it was pretty smart for Zach to
join this tour and get his name out
there more solo artist
don't be afraid this entry is not about
Zach going solo right now he hasn't
spoken of any plans to leave why don't
we but a few years ago Zach did have
some solo projects
what in particular was really successful
and that was his song time lapse it
dropped in 2016 the song was about how
much he wanted to get to know a girl but
never felt like he had enough time which
makes sense when you're on your way to
being a pretty big star in the song he
goes on to say that he'll pretty much
cancel all of his plans for this girl
hello can we get a guy like Zach
favorite music a lot of artists
different musical influences often a
person's musical influence affects the
way that they sound and the way they
create their own musical personas Zach
admitted that his favorite music is the
music that came from the 80s he says
that no matter what comes out the music
from that era will always be his
favorite the 80s did have some pretty
great music can you hear an 80s
influence on the music that Zach
produces next time you're listening to
any of his parts with why don't we pay
close attention you might hear something
that shows off his favorite genre
celebrity crush everyone has a crush on
someone us regular people usually have
to admire our crushes from afar but even
celebrities have crushes we love to find
out what celebrities other celebrities
are crushing on can you guess who's Zach
has a crush on okay we'll give you a
hint
she loves rocking ponytails and she has
one of the most amazing voices we have
ever heard did you guess
of course you did it's ariana grande he
actually talks about his crush pretty
often but we don't really see anything
happening between these two because
she's almost always in a relationship
but you never know maybe he'll catch her
one day when she's single old YouTube
channel sure you probably watch all of
why don't we music videos but we just
can't get enough if you're like us you
probably want to see as much of Zach as
possible well you're in luck Zach
actually has an old YouTube channel that
is still up the channel was called bro
trio it featured him and his friends it
shows a completely different side of
Zach instead of focusing on his singing
the channel focuses on him and his
friends just goofing around and having
fun the channel is a great way to get to
know a little more about Zach working on
himself honing your craft is a lifelong
journey you can always get better at
what you do no matter what your talent
is though Zach had toured before he said
that the group's recent invitation tour
made him a better performer the tour had
longer sets lots of outfit changes and
ultimately bigger audiences at first
Zach was a little intimidated by all of
the things that his tour required of him
but after a while of doing it he
realized that it was making him a better
artist and for
former we all need experiences like this
to push us to be better so good for you
Zac inspiration like we mentioned before
artists are inspired by a lot of things
depending on the situation an artist
could be inspired by the circumstances
of their own lives or by others while we
mentioned earlier that Zac is greatly
influenced by 80's music
he's also influenced greatly by John bel
ian if you don't know who that is he's
best known for his single all-time low
you might be wondering how someone with
such a different sound could inspire Zac
but people can be inspired by anyone
it'd be boring if they are only inspired
by people who sounded and acted exactly
like them we would honestly love to see
a Zac John mashup wouldn't you first
song we all know that Zac can play the
guitar it's part of what made us like
him in the first place he's just so
multi-talented do you know what the
first song he learned on the guitar was
it was actually thinking out loud by Ed
Sheeran which is pretty interesting if
you think about it because ed Sheeran is
the one that wrote why don't we song
trust fun baby
isn't that insane can you imagine
learning a song by one of your favorite
artists only to have the artist
eventually write a song for you that's
crazy
Zach must have been so excited covers a
lot of stars start out singing covers
covers are a great way to get noticed
because people already like those songs
and are searching for them on YouTube
and other channels so it's easier for
people to happen upon your music when
you're singing a cover than if you were
singing an original song this could have
been the reason that Zach did a cover of
Sean Mendez's
stitches and it's a good thing that he
did because the video went viral after
he posted it on YouTube he got millions
of views and it pretty much solidified
that he was on his way to doing big
things constantly winning with a voice
like Zach's it only makes sense that he
would be constantly winning things as we
mentioned before Zach was in a choir in
high school while in the choir he won
several honors but the awards didn't
stop there he was also selected as one
of the youngest members of the master
select program for up-and-coming artists
by Entertainment Group it's like the kid
was created for greatness from a young
age he was winning awards left and right
his parents had to have known that he
wouldn't just be an ordinary kid and
look at him now
he's a star family life family is
important just because you're a star
doesn't mean that you don't need people
behind you that support you and always
have your back
typically your family are the ones who
will always be with you no matter what
Zacks parents are named Mita and Josh
Herron and he is one of three kids he
has a younger brother named Ryan and a
younger sister named Reese it's probably
really exciting for his younger siblings
to watch him rise up and become such a
big star it also opens the door for them
to become stars as well if that's what
they want to do completely inspired by
ed sheeran it's not just the very first
why don't we song that connected the
band to Ed Sheeran it turns out ed
Sheeran is a huge role model for Zach in
an interview with Inc pop he revealed
that Ed Sheeran has actually been a big
influence for him as a musician Zach
said that a lot of their music is
inspired by Ed's talent of giving songs
a brand new meaning we can totally
understand why Ed Sheeran is just one of
those artists that brings out a lot of
emotions in his songs he's been a
complete inspiration to Zach when it
came to writing music in general and
Zach said Edie is a great writer and a
great person too before the invitation
tour before the invitation tour
Zach's career was very different he said
they didn't really have production and
music to show before they just had one
EP out with only five songs but then
they got a full hour and 15 minutes set
which is crazy to think about the first
day on tour Zach got nervous because
there were a lot of people watching them
it's quite scary being on a big stage
for the first time and all he could
think about were outfit changes and how
could he possibly change in such short
amount of time it takes a lot of skill
to be a performer doesn't it feelings on
the group one of the best and hardest
parts about being part of a band is that
you're constantly in a group you're
compared to your group mates and you
always have to spend time around each
other you don't like the other people in
your group then it kind of sucks to be
you but luckily Zach doesn't feel that
way about his group what's up it's why I
know we in an interview he said that
being in a band was a big thing for him
because it meant that he got to share
his experiences with four other guys
that's just a dope guy there are people
to laugh with about the crazy things
that happen
and someone to share everything with
they work like crazy in an exclusive
interview in March 2018 Zack spoke about
what the band's plans were after their
tour what he ended up doing is actually
revealing just how crazy they work Zack
said that after the tour wraps up
they'll go on to their European tour and
while they're touring they'll be
recording new things he said he hopes
they'll be releasing an album which is
crazy to think about why don't we work
so hard to make their music usually it
takes bands forever to come out with new
music
imagine recording new songs as you're
also trying to remember all old ones and
performing on stage almost every night
that is exhausting Dreamgirl we've
already mentioned that Zack has a pretty
big crush on ariana grande but he
probably knows that is a long shot when
it really comes down to it Zack has said
that he doesn't need someone famous he
just needs someone that he has a
connection with if a girl can make him
laugh and I make him happy then he's
more than good with that he said that
the main thing for him is that they
connect instantly and right off the bat
that's how he will know that it's meant
to be you hear that girls
better start practicing your jokes now
if you want to be with Zack Filipino
fans Zack and the rest of the group are
extremely grateful for all the fans they
have gained over the years but in an
interview Zack was quick to point out
one group in particular quote I see you
guys Filipinos everywhere on the
internet on social media he said every
time he gets on social media those fans
are just blowing up his notifications
and he couldn't wait to go to the
Philippines
he said his Filipino fans were just
freaking out over their music and always
sharing their content so he said a
special thank you to his Filipino fans
for all that and sent his love birthday
some people think that you can tell a
lot about a person based on their
birthday well Zack was born on May 27
2001 this makes him a Gemini Gemini's
are said to be expressive and
quick-witted the sign represents two
different personalities in one the
problem is you never know which
personality type you'll get with these
people they are also very sociable and
are always down for a good time they do
however have a tendency to become
Restless and serious Gemini's typically
want to see and experience everything
and constantly worry that there isn't
enough time for them to see and do
everything that they want to do
imitation if you were famous would you
ever spend your time trying to be
someone else probably not why would you
famous people have everything at their
fingertips money fans cars houses pretty
much everything but still it can be
pretty funny to pretend to be someone
else from time to time which is probably
why Zack loves to do imitations of Harry
Styles and surprisingly he's pretty good
at it
could this mean that Zack has some
acting skills that we don't know about
we sure hope so because we would love to
see Zack in a movie or two wouldn't you
well that's it for 20 things you didn't
know about Zack heron from why don't we
were you surprised by anything on this
list did we miss anything let us know in
the comments
[Music]